the investigation into Russian
interference in the election has reached
a potential turning point Special
Counsel Robert Muller is reportedly now
scrutinizing whether President Trump
tried to obstruct justice allegations of
obstruction surfaced after the president
fired James Comey as FBI director this
morning the president tweeted quote they
made up a phony collusion with the
Russian story found zero proof so now
they go for obstruction of justice on
the phony story nice
Maji guard is at the White House major
good morning good morning CBS News has
learned a Dan Coates Director of
National Intelligence has agreed to be
interviewed by Special Counsel Robert
Muller one of the topics his
conversations with President Trump about
the Russia investigation now according
to the Washington Post the special
counsels probe will now look into
whether or not President Trump attempted
to obstruct justice looking into that
question doesn't necessarily mean
evidence will be found or a charge will
be brought a spokesman for Trump's
personal attorney mark caso it said the
FBI leak of information regarding the
president is outrageous inexcusable and
illegal there is no proof at the moment
the FBI is the source of this leak
National Security Agency director Mike
Rogers is also cooperating CBS News has
reported the president asked Rogers and
Coates to push back against the
narrative of cooperation between his
campaign and Russian operatives into
2016 election
the two men refused to answer questions
about those conversations during Senate
testimony last week a former FBI
director James Comey did testify that
the president asked him to try to lift
the cloud of the Russia investigation
and when he did not Jeff the president
fired him major here at the White House
major thanks very much